نتابع من تجارب كوريا الشماليه الصاروخيه
واختراق طيرانها المسير لاجواء الشقيقه
اللدوده كوريا الجنوبيه ما اثر المخاوف في
شرق اسيا المتجه نحو مزيدا من التوتر
التنين والصيني الجامح وحليفه في بيونجا
محطه انظار العالم اخترق الطائرات مسيره
تابعه لكوريا
مؤخرا خرق لم يتحرك الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
لمواجهته كما يجب على ما يبدو بناء على
اتفاق امني وقع عام 2018 الاتفاق المذكوره
وقع على هامشي قمه بين الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي ورئيس كوريا الجنوبيه حينها
مونجيئين يدعو الى وقفه كل التصرفات
الغذائيه واقامه منطقه حضر طيران على
الحدود اضافه الى ازاله الالغام الارضيه
ومواقع حرس الحدود داخل المنطقه منزوعات
السلاح شديده التحصين اتفاقه ان انتقده
الرئيس الجديد لكوريا
يونج
الطائرات الكوريه الشماليه بدون طيار
مجالنا الجوي هو حادث لا يطاق كثير من
الناس كانوا قلقين يجب ان نضع كوريا
الشماليه تعلم ان الاستفزازات تقابل دائما
بعواقب وخيمه يجب ان نراجع نظام الاستجابه
الشامل لدينا ضد جميع الاجسام الطائره
التي تنتهي كوما جانا الجوي وان نحسن على
الفورعدنك
اكثر صرامه ضد شاره الشماليه هدد بتعليق
الاتفاق العسكري انف الذكر في حال اخترقت
بيوم بيونغا المجال الجويه لبلاده مجددا
ولم
يكتفيول بتهديده بل دعى جيش بلاده الى
بنائه قدره رد ساحقه تتجاوزه حدود التناسب
منتقدا بالوقت نفسه طريقه تعامل الجيش مع
حادثه الطائرات المسيره
الحمد لله سواء كانت لديه مصلحه نوويه او
اي نوع من اسلحه الدمار الشامل يجب ان
نرسل رساله واضحه الى الاشخاص الذين
يقومون بالاستفزازات بشكل متكرر ويجب ان
لا نخاف منهم او نتردد
وتزامنا او تجاوبا مع دعوه الرئيس امر
وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي بتدشيني وحده
شامله للطائرات المسيره تقوم بمهم متعدده
بما يشمل المراقبه والاستطلاع والحرب
الالكترونيه وانشاء منظومه لانتاج كميات
كبيره من الطائرات المسيره الصغيره التي
يصعب اكتشافها خلال العام الحالي الاتجاه
نحو التسليح وخلق منظومات جديده لم تلتفت
اليه فقط بل الجاره اليابان ايضا التي
زادت بشكل مهول الميزانيتها الدفاعيه
لمواجهه ما اسمته تحديدا استراتيجيا غير
مسبوق من قبل الصين
[موسيقى]